I have yet another one of these
horrifying stories about the brutal
Putin regime that were still sort of
trying to figure out I told you a while
back that Mikhail lesson was found dead
in his Washington DC hotel room back in
November of 2015
okay lesson was vladimir putin's former
media czar and the date of his death is
November 5 2015 that's relevant because
on November 6 2015 he was scheduled to
meet with the US Justice Department
reportedly to talk about the inner
workings of Russian propaganda channel
RT which lesson himself helped create
but of course he never made it to the
interview because he was found dead he
was found dead with blunt force injuries
to the head neck and torso and after a
year of so-called investigation a
federal prosecutor announced that lezin
died alone in his room due to drunkenly
falling multiple times after drinking
for days the death was ruled an accident
and the case was closed as far as
prosecutors were concerned however we
now have two FBI agents speaking out
saying that is not what happened they
say that lesson was actually murdered
bludgeoned to death in fact we have a
quote from one of these FBI agents with
knowledge of the incident lesson was
beaten to death I would implore you to
say as much there seems to be an effort
here to cover up that fact for reasons I
can't get into what I can tell you is
that there isn't a single person inside
the bureau who believes this guy got
drunk fell down and died everyone thinks
he was whacked and that Putin or the
Kremlin were behind it one of these
officials went as far as to say a
baseball bat was the particular tool
that was used in the bludgeoning of
Mikhail lesson at the time lesson was
working for state-owned Gazprom media
about a year before this incident he was
working for Gazprom media he abruptly
resigned in 2014 he reportedly had a
falling-out with Vladimir Putin's close
confidants and went into hiding abroad
and the hypothesises that he sort of
became a liability for Vladimir Putin
when a letter was written by
u.s. senator Roger wicked to the Justice
Department asking for them to
investigate what was going on with
lesson and this is yet another one of
these suspicious Russian deaths BuzzFeed
did a two year investigation into 14
Russian deaths that were suspicious on
British soil most of which were ignored
by the UK government and as usual Pat
with lots of these including lessons
death we get reports that don't really
make sense about the cause of death we
go to the medical examiner that was
involved they say you know we're barred
by law from giving you the OP top see
details and he fell multiple times from
being too drunk is is weird like is
there an amount of alcohol that would
cause you so you could have a lot of
alcohol and fall once and pass out and
maybe you would have like one injury
from that but to believe that you're
drinking so much but still staying
conscious and falling multiple times in
your own house hotel room until you die
is weird it's because they have to work
backwards with the explanation so if he
was actually bludgeoned to death with a
baseball bat
you'd imagine that he was attacked from
multiple angles probably hit multiple
times so you can't just blame that on
one fall it has to be multiple to of
multiple falls and it's the same thing
as someone being stabbed in the back 11
times before falling out of a building I
mean it's it's a ridiculous explanation
so then the question becomes presumably
someone or some combination of people
want to cover this up if indeed this was
a Kremlin sanctioned ordered Kremlin
involved hit then there are people in
the u.s. complicit in the cover-up why
would they do that and then it becomes
speculation are there people in the
Department of Justice allied with
Vladimir Putin and they don't want to
upset Putin are there people in the
Department of Justice that are sort of
just aware of how the situation would
become hysterical if you start seeing
headlines saying hey here's what really
happened and maybe they want to avoid
escalation with Russia a sort of
realpolitik perspective I don't know I
don't know but there is a very long list
a growing list of these suspicious
deaths